hey youtubers is Charlie Zack Snyder
dropped another Justice League destro
teaser so this is gonna be a breakdown
it just gives us an idea for like what
he's actually gonna be doing in the
movie Zack Snyder posted this picture of
the other day just saying Justice League
cosplay like it was no big deal just
having fun behind the scenes still
working on the movie still a lot of
Justice League movie left to be made
he's got one of Batman's new arm
gauntlets it looks like it's been
modified just a little bit pretty
modular if he can just put one glove on
at a time but then when you zoom and
enhance CSI style like zoom enhanced
zoom enhance at his iPad here that he's
messing with storyboards on you see a
meeting between Deathstroke and Lex
Luthor so it looks like that's the
reason Deathstroke enters the story like
Lex Luthor hires him in orders a hit on
Batman and the Justice League so
wherever they take that that will be
part of the Justice League movie Zack
Snyder is not making the Batman movie so
any Deathstroke stuff that he's working
on he's only gonna be in Justice League
but obviously we know that he's going to
be in the Batman solo film so as you can
imagine with a lot of comic book
villains whatever ends up happening in
the movie there will be unfinished
Deathstroke Batman business that they
will pick up on during the Batman solo
film and if you didn't see that Batman
video I posted a couple days ago the CEO
of Time Warner said that they're about
18 months out on the Batman solo film
but I think that's him just giving a
preliminary guest there's no indication
that they're done with the script for
that so I'm guessing that movie is gonna
be some time during 2019 so it's still a
ways off we're still talking about
Justice League here and there is still
that rumor that we're gonna get a really
big Justice League official trailer
around Christmastime which i think is
pretty likely like usually a couple big
things drop around then we have a Star
Wars movie
we have guardians of the galaxy to
footage that James Gunn's confirmed of
dropping around that time of the year in
any other big thing that Marvel wants to
draw so probably some spider-man Home
Coming too because that movie is coming
out a little bit after garden to the
galaxy 2 so all the studio's DC Marvel
are trying to end the year with a bang
so let me know what do you actually
think Deathstroke is going to be doing
for Lex Luthor during Justice League is
it just a simple hit do you think he's
gonna be like all right I want you to
kill all of those people right over
there just kill him any way you want to
I don't care
I'll give you all the money in the world
because Deathstroke has a code of honor
he's not just gonna go kill people
because he hates them he only kills
people when there's a contract for their
life but I wouldn't be surprised if they
try to build out his backstory just a
little bit just so that he's not
completely Boba Fett in the movie if
it's been a long time Boba Fett
obviously a really awesome cool Star
Wars character but when he first debuted
there wasn't really a backstory you just
knew that he was this badass bounty
hunter that didn't really talk just
stood there looking stone-cold then when
we got to Empire Strikes Back he got a
little bit more badass but because we
have Joe Manganiello playing the
character you expect him to be able to
walk around without the mask on and if
they really want to get crazy with his
character they'll let one of the Justice
League members like Batman take his eye
out but I don't know how hardcore
they're gonna make this movie that would
push it closer to an R rating and
they're wanting the movie to feel a
little more hopeful so let me know if
you think they're gonna do more a comic
book Deathstroke and he'll only have one
eye when we first see him in the movie
or if he'll have two eyes and then at
some point in the movie he'll lose one
of them and become more comic-book II
Deathstroke by the end of the film
usually I would say it's more fun if
you're introduced to a character who's
already had their origin story and then
you slowly tease that out with dialogue
turns of phrase references that they
make over the course of whatever new
adventure they're having in the story so
like Deathstroke comes in to Justice
League probably be best if he's already
fully Deathstroke just going after the
Justice League and then as he's going
after them you learn little bits about
his backstory in the DC movie universe
because I do think it'll be very comic
book II but they change comic book
stories just a little bit so you have to
already imagine the Deathstroke has had
all these crazy adventures to earn the
reputation that he has before he ever
sets foot in this movie so there's like
all this untold Deathstroke story like
you can make a whole movie just about
Deathstroke but part of the fun as fans
is just trying to figure that out so you
don't really need to write fanfic you
just go out and you buy the destro comic
book and it'll tell you everything you
need to know about the character and if
you haven't been reading it Deathstroke
rebirth is really cool they just debuted
the Ravager character they had a couple
flashback
recently where you learn about Jericho
his other children and you see Billy
wintergreen his comrade-in-arms who kind
of gives him his mission so to speak but
based on the amount of comic book
changes they made in Batman V Superman
and the other DC movies so far I'm just
I'm expecting a few tweaks like a few
nips and tucks to the destro comic book
backstory so like he'll probably have
already crossed paths with a lot of
these other DC characters that we've met
with the exception of like Superman and
Wonder Woman because Wonder Woman's been
hiding out since World War one as of the
beginning of Batman V Superman and she's
just come back into the public spotlight
the flash has been keeping it on the DL
even though he's been around for a
little while same thing with Aquaman the
world only just learned about Superman
so Deathstroke probably hadn't run into
him before but Amanda Waller all the
Suicide Squad characters I would be
willing to bet that they definitely know
who Slade Wilson is especially Amanda
Waller Amanda Waller is like one of the
few other people besides Batman that
collects information on everybody both
villains and superheroes but just
remember even though Deathstroke is
gonna be kicking the out of the
Justice League at least a little bit
he's not technically a villain it's just
that any time Batman appears in a movie
you automatically assume that he's the
hero so anybody that fights him becomes
the antagonist by default so like Harley
Quinn even though she's the hero of the
Suicide Squad movie she would be the
antagonist of a Batman movie depending
on how they use her but if it wasn't
clear this is actually something really
interesting happening with the DC movies
right now and it's not that big of a
surprise most of you probably picked up
on it is that Batman has really started
to dominate it one he's assembling the
Justice League so he's kind of the lead
of the Justice League movie to the other
movies that they've made have heavily
involved his character or involve
characters from his rogues gallery like
Harley Quinn in the Joker in the next
big film they're talking about making is
that Harley Quinn movie so like the
flash and Aquaman are two of the only
characters right now whose movies we
know they're making who didn't start out
in a Batman comic so you can't really
say that Batman's dominating their
storylines but I don't think anybody's
surprised that this is a very Batman
Heavy D see movie universe he's one of
the most popular comic book characters
of all time Ben Affleck had a great
performance he was one of the best parts
of Batman V Superman so naturally they
double down on that just like okay
everybody likes this we will give you a
whole lot of Batman so I don't think
that's a bad thing but I do think it's
interesting when you think about what's
going on in the larger context so let me
know what do you think about the idea of
Deathstroke versus Batman in Justice
League and then later in the Batman solo
film and then what do you think about
the idea of a Batman dominated DC movie
universe we should probably just call it
the bat first even though that's a bit
misleading because there are a lot of
other really big characters though
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner
Wyatt Phillips you win a $20 Amazon gift
card be sure to private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details there is a new
round of the DC giveaway too all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video the flash
and arrow are back next week there will
be another flash video that I'll make
next then I'll be making another Luke
Cage episode video so you still got
plenty of time to binge Luke Cage but
I'll add links for all that stuff in the
description while you guys wait for that
to post you can click here for my Luke
Cage Easter eggs from the first couple
of episodes and you can click here for
the superhero Fight Club trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys can I